it's not called a piece head it's a
warhead yeah because it's gonna wreak
war on your head yeah I mean I remember
warheads just love them this like an
elementary school kid I have not had a
warhead since I was probably 10 years
old so it's been a minute my warhead it
was like a rite of passage I feel like
you became a team when you're able to
eat a warhead without making a face you
just I just love like the intensity of
it kind of kind of nervous like if we up
is a kid okay all right I've already
like sense it and I feel like I'm gonna
cry I think so too
I'm getting excited it's like like when
you go to a roller coaster for the first
time a long time you're like all the
sensations are coming back to you oh
yeah see yeah like let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
I can feel it oh there it is oh boy
you
[Music]
yeah go now now like a tongue drum I
don't know if it's because monstery now
[ __ ] we had so many yo like it hurts
right tom hurts do not my mountain hurts
I could also be the way just ate 5
warheads in a row
maybe I'm like maybe don't do this at
home maybe don't go through five
warheads and once a day I think the kid
I like them because it was like the rush
yeah of the sour and kind of being like
able to power through it to get to a
sweet I'm a little ashamed that the last
one hurt me so bad so mom I'm sorry I'm
sorry that 15 years later I'm out here
eating warheads you're probably watching
this like I thought I raised you better
but it's ok because I won't do this
again opponent I know what if the sour
just kills all the bacteria and it's
just like a genius way to market it just
sanitizers your mouth think about it
think about it yeah maybe
[Music]